Okay, let's take a look at some formal measures of
data quality. There are essentially five measures of data quality that
I'd like to talk about. This is the model we'll
use in this course. And regardless of who's talking about data
quality, and what labels they apply to measures data quality.
They're going to fall roughly into these five categories that we'll talk
about. So first let's talk about validity. With validity, we're
measuring the degree to which entries in our data set conform
to a defined schema, or to other constraints we
might have. As we move through this lesson, we'll discuss
each of these in more detail. Here, I'm just
going to provide an overview. We can also look at
accuracy. This is the degree to which entries conform
to gold standard data. What I mean by that, is
probably best expressed with an example. So, do all street
addresses in a data set that we're cleaning, actually exist?
In order to test that type of accuracy question,
we would need some gold standard. That is, some set
of data that we actually trust. Completeness is pretty straightforward,
do we have all the records we should have? While
explaining it, is pretty straightforward, actually measuring completeness is a
very difficult thing to do. We also want to look
for consistency within our data. In many systems, we will
have multiple records, that have some overlap in the data
they contain. We want to ensure that there is consistency among
the fields, that represent the same data across systems. And finally
uniformity, this one's easy. Do all our values for distance, for
example, use the same units? Is it miles, or is it kilometers?